looking for me outside in yeah people
who are getting
upset at the fact that you're making
comedy at these situations to me
that is potentially the most shocking
thing of all
because amanda yanucci must be itching
at his script to have a go at brexit and
boris johnson with another season of the
thick of it
and there must be you know there must it
is the i think he said he could never do
the thicker thing again there was an
article a couple years ago
because of because he says things have
got to be surreal well yeah there we go
but you know i mean like to me it looks
like the perfect breeding ground the
current political climate
is the perfect breeding ground for some
comedy and some saturn yeah yeah of
course
yeah it's it's ideal um people haven't
said that to me like isn't it hard
to saturate like people like trump who
is self-satisfied the funniest thing
said about trump are by himself
right they're on his twitter feed yeah
you're right you know i mean um
two days ago with the talib you know the
thing about rashida talib who
who'd write sorry talking politics again
but she didn't she'd asked um
to go to israel to visit her 90 year old
grandmother on humanitarian grounds and
israel had denied her entry and because
she was likely to criticize
the israeli government um and she said
she said in a letter i won't mention
pogba
i won't criticize you i just want to see
my grandmother they came back saying
okay
and then she was like oh this is
disgusting i'm not going there because i
demanding that i say certain things it
was a total political
move but then trump tweeted about it
saying well the only winner in this
situation is her grandmother who won't
have to see it
let's be honest that's a funny tweet now
look
i don't support trump and i'm also kind
of i'm old-fashioned about policy i
don't want my politician to be funny
yeah i want that to be serious because
it's a serious job but i can look at
that and say that's funny i can look at
that and say
that's a funny tweet he has a point even
though i don't like most of what he
stands for wish i'd written it
yeah there we go that's not that good
yeah but it's funnier because it's the
president
yeah there is something funny about the
idea of the president of the united
states
calling kim jong-un fat that's funny
because it should never happen it's also
scary because they're both nuclear
powers
you know so the stakes are pretty much
but yeah
well yeah stakes are pretty high there
um so again i should reiterate
i'm not supportive of it i wish he
didn't do it yeah but i also look at it
and laugh
what are you gonna do laughter is an
involuntary response isn't it i don't
calculate like like the woke set seem to
be able to do yeah i mean the woke idea
is that you you look you hear a joke
you think about it you assess who are
the marginalized groups
is it punching up is it punching down uh
can i laugh at that yes good
emit laughter they see it as this kind
of transaction right that's not how it
works
sometimes i laugh at the most horrible
inappropriate things because they are
horrible and inappropriate
because that sort of stuff reminds us
why we don't talk about those things
you're going to see a jerry sadowicz
show
you know and and good luck watching a
jerry sandwich show and not being
offended at some point yeah
everyone's gonna get it he's gonna
offend you at some point there's gonna
be a moment where you think
that's that's too much you shouldn't do
that um and that's part of there's
something quite exhilarating about that
yeah you can be offended and laugh at it
happens to me all the time i'm quite
sensitive i get offended really easily
but it's my problem it's basically
yeah that's funny um one of the things
i've been thinking about when
seeing the way that we recently had zubi
on the show yeah
um because of this
weird gameplay yeah the left's done with
uh language and social constructs and
things like that
yeah to me what it appears to have
allowed are very clever people to game
that system
right and zooby's tweet about um
breaking the woman's deadlift record psi
identified as a woman don't be a bigot
yeah that is a perfect example of
regaining this
the the little gaps that have been
created by the left in that yeah is that
one of the
one of the things that you think that um
is
helping us to identify where there's
inconsistencies within their views and
stuff
i think ridicule is what does it best of
all and and part of the way you do that
is you take on board their language
the problem with that is you find
yourself tempted to play
them by their rules so when they talk
about privilege and
i've seen this happen a lot and there's
an argument about privilege and they
often throw out this idea of white
privilege
this blanket idea that if you're white
you are inherently privileged which of
course is not true
uh some white people are privileged some
are right in all sorts of ways
there's all kinds of ways you can be
privileged right it's not just to do
with race ethnicity and sexuality
um but yeah so you end up with a
situation where
um people buy into the victimhood thing
and they'll say
okay i've been accused of being
privileged so how can i come back and
say actually you know
i i went to a rough school i went grew
up on the state i didn't read it
and then you're getting into this
competitor you're playing their rules
back at them
and that's probably not healthy you know
you can do it like you can
and when they fall foul of their own
rules which they often do
right did you see the the democrat
conference in america where
someone made a point of personal
privilege yeah yeah and the point of
personal privilege
was guys can you just keep the noise
down because i'm very sensitive i get
sensory overload and i get triggered
then someone said point to personal
privilege about that point of personal
privilege
uh don't say guys that's gendered
language i'm really offended by that
don't do that
so you have people calling out each
other's calling out it's like this
endless inception of
wokeness yeah right so so we could do
that too
so we could we could point out where
they are being triggering i mean let's
let's take an example
most of the workload who are really
anti-brexit
tend to be incredibly ageist they're
basically saying we can't wait for the
old people to die
old people have [__] over the country
they're basically evil
it's like are you kidding you're you
know you're the person who goes on all
the time about being sensitive
and and uh you know and surely what
ageism is part of that isn't it or is
that just your blind spot
so then if we call them out for ages and
we become part of that game yeah
so i sort of refuse to play the game so
that's that's something that i've been
i've got written down here as something
that i told you can't work out but
you're going to help me do it okay you
may have been in a relationship but a
lot of listeners will have been
where your partner brings up a
particular issue
you don't care about this issue okay
that you spoke to
that girl or um you didn't reply in time
or you're
you were late or something like that
that's not an issue that you usually
would do
but they set a precedent by doing that
yeah and then
what you find yourself doing next time
that something happens that you find
them culpable for that same thing for
yeah is you go hang on a second are you
talking to that guy
yeah i didn't care and i still don't
care but i'm going to use the
opportunity to identify your
inconsistency yeah that's fine straight
off the bat
yeah and that push and pull yeah that
happens in relationships
i think is very similar to what's
happening here yeah i almost think that
looking at the way that the left has
kind of adopted this
the way that uh andy noah was assaulted
in the street and taking bike lots
around and throwing milkshakes at people
you know that would have been a
characteristic of the right
previously oh it's been a very
aggressive approach right and it's
almost like
they're um absorbing taking on that
persona
that push and pull thing and then you
think well hang on a second if you keep
on doing that as the left
and throwing bike locks around there are
some people on the right who have got
very very large guns right exactly well
there's two there's two sort of points
there i think i think one of them is
is well actually not just the left that
do it because the right do it as well we
saw that with the joe brown case you
know when joe brown made the joke about
throwing battery acid at nigel farage
which was obviously a joke
uh whether you found it funny or not
that's irrelevant um
but it was most people on the right
saying she should be arrested
or she should be investigated by the
police all the same people who complain
about the very authoritarian treatment
of comedy on the whole right
and people who complain you say that
free speech is under threat
and then all of a sudden they're the
people saying actually no but joe brown
should be
investigators that's the inciting
violence no you've got to be consistent
in your principles
either left or right that's really
really important because it means
your own principles will get undermined
um the other point about antifa
which the the group the anti-fascist
group now i for one mistrust anyone who
identifies as anti-fascist
let me just say that because for a star
i assume everyone is
right my assumption of you will be that
you're not a fascist
yeah it's fair assumption right yeah
okay um
i will assume that everyone until i hear
extraordinary evidence
to the contrary if i find the evidence
fine yeah but but we have to us
because there's hardly any fascists out
there it's like an
yeah exactly exactly you don't declare
that do you yeah you don't declare that
you don't have a predilection
to penetrate livestock do you do you i
don't know
and i wouldn't assume that you would
have yeah
you know although now we're talking
about it my suspicions are you see but
look
and i see on twitter all the time
anti-fat proud anti-fascists like you
don't need to tell me that
and it makes me suspicious what you're
projecting about yeah exactly it's the
same as the
the people who there's a statistic
somewhere that yusef one of the co-hosts
of the show's put out
yeah people that are very very sort of
vitriolic about um
being against gays yeah are the ones
that are most aroused when they see
yeah there's been studies into that yeah
they've been studying i mean they
literally measured
the extent of people's arousal yeah you
know to like
how hard they got basically on the and
and it tended to be
when when the the most overtly
homophobic watch gay porn
it's so it's but it's such a no-brainer
of course it is because why would you
care
yeah why would you care if people unless
there's something lurking in the back of
yeah it's pretty it's you know i mean
the data's in on that one yeah and it's
not surprising
um but the point about antifa yeah
antifa effectively end up behaving like
uh fascists don't they end up behaving
that's the thing that's so funny about
it yeah
like anyone who seeks to silence someone
through violence
is is at the very least employing a
tactic that the fascists also employed
so you know i probably stopped short of
calling them actual fascists i think
fascists are very specific
historical meaning but there are
certainly fascistic uh tendencies or
or strategies um i mean i read uh brett
mark bray i think mark bray's book about
antifa
and what's very interesting it's very
well written actually what's interesting
about it is
he does a very uh good job of sort of
outlining all the history of the
anti-fascist movements
things like cable street you know um
whether the people confronted the oswald
mosley's
brown shirts so all of that and that's
very good there's a lot of that stuff i
didn't know about it's all very
interesting but of course those are
genuine anti-fascist
movements you know these are the you
know not the kidneys version
right exactly so what what the book
fails to do quite spectacularly actually
is connect those movements to what is
happening now
and makes the assumption that the people
we're dealing with are in fact fascists
but that assumption is wrong okay so
some of them are fascists
some of them are white supremacists sure
right most of them are
you saw you see trump supporters getting
pepper sprayed people anyone wearing a
maga hat
getting kicked to the ground there was
someone who had a make bitcoin great
again hat
that got really just because they didn't
read it properly yeah they couldn't read
the
bitcoin instead of now if you can't
distinguish between an actual white
supremacist
and someone who votes trump and that
isn't to say that white supremacists
couldn't vote trump they could
and they might do but just because you
vote trump it doesn't follow that you're
a white supremacist that will still be a
massive minority
of the people who voted for trump right
so if you can't make that distinction
then you are politically and
historically illiterate
and what's worse is if you can't make
that distinction and you have that level
of literacy
and you've got a baseball bat and a mask
that's a dangerous combination
right totally right you know i mean we
saw with andy know a bunch of
white middle-class students in masks
beating up
a gay vietnamese immigrant in
the name of tolerance in the name of
tolerance and to do you know
to stand up against white supremacy are
you choking it's a titania tweet so it's
really funny and also horrible
yeah it's horrible because sorry andrew
he well yeah he was hurt he was injured
it was unjust um what they should have
done now obviously all the stems from
from an article he wrote or a couple of
articles he wrote for colette what you
do in that case if you disagree with the
journalist is you go to them and say
oh i disagree with this can we have a
discussion about it
that's it and as soon as you hit someone
on the basis of oh they are
normalizing uh supremacist language or
discourse you
you know you over theorize to justify
your own violent acts
and it can't be justified
and it's really really sad that we've
got to this point where this is
[Music]
happening